sono risolti se uno che da un pochettino
non registrava rocket oggi un episodio
non si parla di minuto dentro i fritti o
sotto i letti quindi meno male allora
ragazzi questo è un discorso che non
c'entra assolutamente nulla con rob e
maliziosa e una cosa che è successa
londero scuola allora lo spiego
particolari su presupposti a scola non
sono mai stato un fenomeno
ok cioè non sono mai stato avevo sempre
voti sufficienti tipo 67 tra le materie
umanistiche gli avevo 8 9 prove
matematica 0 comunque il discorso nasce
dal fatto che all'ora che mi sono
iscritto ad una scuola di informatica e
adesso mi vedete fare i video ai tempi
giravo su internet guardavi pochi video
che c'erano su youtube
dunque passavamo il sacco di tempo sacco
di tempo al computer sapevo anche molto
bene l'inglese perché surf are the
internet ci permetteva di imparare bene
l'inglese infatti ho iniziato ad andare
alle elementari che già sapevo l'inglese
meglio che quelli delle medie
insomma ho vissuto un sacco di tempo al
computer tant'è vero che quei pochi
laboratori che facevo le medie di
informatica insomma io ero un fenomeno
che lupi scriveva sulla tastiera tale
che vuole da tastiera certa ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta i miei compagni era un
tipo
dopo le medie la scelta della scuola mi
è sembrata diceva da oggi ha detto farò
informatica già lì fu un problema perché
alle 20 e fanno quella roba che si
chiama orientamento che cos'è
praticamente ti aiutano a capire che
strada vuoi prendere dopo le medie e tra
le varie scelte tu devi crocettare
quella che ti sembrava più consono in io
alzo la mano mi scusi prof
io vorrei fare informatica che vi a me
piace prova matematica mi fa cagare da
propri pareri fa e non è un controsenso
se ti piace di formati che deve piacere
anche la matematica cosa chiamati caste
e io ero tipo ma io io io sono da anni
al computer che già smanettava
programmavo creavo i primi virus
gli hacker salvatore aranzulla di di
spostare e facendo tutte ste cose qua
però di matematica non sapeva una certa
di minchia se andavo da cani matematica
andavo già da casa
nelle medie ovviamente ho scelto
comunque la scuola di matematica e
informatica istituto tecnico informatico
molto verbo è servito volto l'istituto
tecnico informatico nella mia vita
perché io da lì poi non è servita un
cazzo però ho fatto lo youtuber perché
ho conosciuto le mie amici che ho
conosciuto appunto li farei meno male
quindi non avevo scelto l'informatico
allora informatica la inizia a fare dopo
i primi dopo dopo i dopo i primi due
anni due anni non fa informatica quasi
inizia al triennio inizia a fare
informatico ok del biennio io ho fatto
cagare
ovviamente la perizia di parola di
attuare le si inizia informatica
finalmente una materia nella quale vado
bene inizia ragazzi informatica è la mia
prima lezione in assoluto di informatica
terza superiore quindi facciamo
l'appello e bla bla bla
arriviamo al punto in cui ci sono io o
studi presente e lì mi guarda e papà tu
sarai mica parente di dio soli
professore così mi dice siccome ragazzi
lei era ormai la tipo era quarta volta
nella stessa giornata mi pare perché
quando fa il triennio cambi praticamente
quasi tutti i professori no crea la
quarta persona ma l'aveva detto durante
la giornata e gli ho detto no non ho
scelto non sono assolutamente parente
del professore non è che perché abbiamo
lo stesso cognome siamo parenti ho detto
questa cosa
ok questa professoressa mi risponde così
con tono abbastanza visibilmente
incazzato mi risponde tipo e no alle
volte ci sono degli alunni che hanno lo
stesso [ __ ] vuol dire che sono
proprio parenti ok
certo come se fosse un attacco c che non
è una noi che imitava da una tag chanel
ci mancherebbe altro
la partita non è una battuta era della
serie dai se avete già 24 per leva non
ho mancato di rispetto assolutamente
nessun modo però lei l'ha preso come se
fosse un attacco infatti detto google e
finisce finiamo di presentarci nel pci
alla lezione poi finita la lezione io
vado dalla mia professor da lei e lei di
6 professoressa guardi le chiedo scusa
per prima sembrava c'è da come mi ha
risposto sembrava quasi che che forse si
fosse incavola anche perché io non
l'avevo capito se le stesse scherzando o
meno però era visibilmente incazzata la
valletta guardi con tutta la
tranquillità nel mondo stato d'aiuto
quali non erano leggo sembra stipula
attacco
lei mi quale mi fa passo i tre anni del
tecnico anzi due perché ce l'ho avuta
per due anni nell'ingiustizia più totale
adesso non farò il nome di questa
professoressa però insomma secondo me
persone del genere non dovrebbero fare i
propri c'è non dovrebbero fare questo
lavoro perché con tutto il rispetto del
mondo se fai preferenze il professore
non lo puoi fare cioè cambia mestiere ma
non era logico con cattiveria desso non
me ne frega pigno mi ricordo quasi
neanche il nome dal fabbro anzi non mi
ricordo il nome di questo professore zoe
di cemento però non puoi andare a e non
era l'unica che faceva preferenze non
era assolutamente l'unica a fare
preferenze ti giudicavano dalle
primissime verifiche dalle prime due o
tre verifiche vedevano comandare e poi
ti mettevano voti fino alla fine dei big
dei secoli in poi non guardavano nel gp
complice ti mettevano il voto in base a
come ti chiamavi una volta avevo fatto
io per le tre verifiche di questa
quest'altra professoressa levo fatte
male o per tipo sei male
normale quindi io davvero la
professoressa avevo sei italiano c'e
l'italiano nero mandato sotto il 9 mai
da qualcuna professoressa mo solo sei
solo sei perché aveva mia va corretto le
prime verifiche erano sei
quindi per lei io potrò avere solo 6 set
i pubblico quelli che brava sempre 9
ho provato a mettere il mio il mio nome
nella sua verifica e lui ha messo il suo
nome nella mia e io misticamente ho
preso nove e lui ha preso di 16 e lui ha
preso 6 c'è proprio non si vedeva che
abbiamo capito i nomi i nomi cioè io ho
scritto la mia verifica e poi ho messo
il nome suo lui a sito la sua verifica
ha messo il nome mio
tanto eravamo d'accordo la sua mediana
tipo 9 quindi non cambiava niente e
stranamente stavolta io preso 9 luis è
incredibile
abbiamo fatto questo test incrini quindi
nella mia scuola chan dei professori che
non sapranno fare i professori comunque
su disco serata è una premessa perché la
verità è che i fatti che voglio
raccontarvi non c'entrano relativamente
con questo comunque era per farvi capire
che io ho di formati andò male per
questo motivo arrivo in quarta superiore
e succede una cosa un po strana facciamo
queste chiamate le cosiddette olimpiadi
di informatica che cosa sono le
olimpiadi di informatica la ripieni di
informatica sono dei test ok loghi più o
meno logici l'informatica punto qui tu
prendi tutta la scuola a tutti gli
studenti informati carife fare lo stesso
quiz a tutti ci portano in questa
auditorio gigantesco ok della scuola una
vittoria dove ci stavamo in voi 500
avremmo fatto suo testo e non lo so in
quanti per annunci qualche centinaia di
ragazzi abbiamo fatto questo test
molti se ne sono sbattuti molti ci hanno
provato lo stesso mi sta veramente in
culo fatto di essere giudicato così male
dalla mia professoressa solo per quel
motivo no che ho detto io mi impegno non
mi male per la media ma mi impegno ci
provo e finisco il test consegnavo e
niente poi torniamo tutti la nostra
classe via che passa qualche settimana
insomma durante la lezione di
informatica a un certo punto entra in
classe il preside chi di voi è lorenzo
studi detto no no vi prego no cosa è
successo ma tuttavia detto no no no no
io non faccio mai niente sono zitto
fermo dai cosa volete da me alzo la mano
di medico
salve salzare io sarei il preside
riguarda mi fa ostuni
sei arrivato primo alle olimpiadi di
informatica io questa è stata la mia
reazione in classe giuro ho fatto questa
cosa ho buttato giù gli screen della
classe noi ragazzi io mi sono alzato
dalla sedia che non ci credevo fatto
così davanti a tutti nel silenzio non ci
potevo credere
mi giro verso la professoressa così lei
mi guarda back door incazzata che non è
in casa però mi guarda tipo ma veramente
io ragazzi io sono arrivato primo
ero primo in tutta la sua no di mutu
doppiamente ma in tutta la scuola io
nella classifica arrivato prima ragazzi
quei questa è la foto
questa è la [ __ ] foto delle olimpiadi
di informatica e quel [ __ ] nome in
alto il mio la prof era visibilmente
perché poi secolo e il discorso di scuse
che poi magari il preside va a vedere la
media dei miei voti di informatica
vedere ciò 5 quindi dice ma come gaza è
quindi forse un po nei classici finisce
anche la propria della serie ma scrivo
come fai avere 5 se poi al primo anno
rinviati di informatica allora lei
attentato mi ricordo ha veramente
davanti a tutta la classe è scesa così
in basso da dire non è un insulto non
non era ancora i coperchi questo
professore serata non lo sto dicendo
come insulto lo sto dicendo perché
descrive la realtà come la vedo che lei
è riuscita a dire una roba tipo è stato
veramente così bravo a copiare è la mia
risposta è stata guardi non so se ho
copiato da gesù cristo ma più di me non
ha preso nessuno quindi da chi dopo aver
copiato
lei è riuscita a chi attive che ho
copiato ma da chi che nessuno ha preso
più di me è perché magari alcune lei
copiate alcune lei sparate ma va a
cagare va comunque tutto questo io ho
sempre cercato di avere megaris te anche
se c'è anche se io sapevo e tutti
sapevano perché si vedeva c'era chiaro
il questi fatto di questo odio verso di
me perché l'altro in con di perché a
molti tanto io facevo anche abbastanza
tenerezza perché non facevo niente cioè
stato zitto e l'ho odiato da questa prof
non solo è stato zitto cioè non facevo
niente quindi la gente dice che questo
qua non fa niente non disturbano far
rullare puro piacere dai povero povero
cristo è quindi niente non quello che
voglio dire semplicemente non valete
meno come persone se avete dei voti
bassi
in tutto questo non vuol dire che non vi
troviate impegnare impegnatevi perchè la
scuola il vostro futuro quindi
impegnatevi non voglio passare messaggi
tipo di messaggio
anzi lo tengo quello passare nessun
messaggio con questo virus da
raccontarvi quella che è stata la mia
storia però a prescindere da tutto
questo io da quella volta lì ho fatto
una rivalutazione di me stesso e ho
detto vabbè ma se voti bassi non
significa che non valga neanche in
quella materia va beh iscrivetevi al
canale e schiacciate mi piace questo era
un video po diverso dal solito ma c'è un
po più tranquillo su rocket ma volevo
raccontarvi questa cosa c'è arrivare il
primo nella mia vita in quello è stata
la mia più grande soddisfazione poi
arrivai una volta che prima ha un tono
di freccette per quelle un po meno però
che siamo i ragazzi cerchiamo prossimo
video iscriviti al canale commentate e
savona ragazzi bella
[Musica]